hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to I'm on observation
Duty brightness can be adjusted
can't anyway I never thought that I'd be
back and wanting to try this again but I
actually had success last time it was
stressful but I got through it and I
felt very accomplished I felt like I did
very good and I felt good about myself
the dopamine was rushing and therefore I
want to try it again I can't say that
I'm gonna have any kind of success
though so let's keep trying we'll need
sharp eyes and good memory okay I forget
how to play already
let's do this all right a bodak
we are testing a new Reporting System
what no need to report the anomaly type
anymore only report the room you spotted
the anomaly in but too many false
reports will cause a system
crash oh please note that the men in the
elevator are not anomalies
okay oh boy well this is gonna be this
is gonna be different get out of the way
hair I don't need you right now oh boy
here we go wow those are good comforting
paintings
attention employee anomalies have been
previously cited okay
just need to get this in my memory as
soon as possible so that I can at least
see them all
and then I'll be fine
papers I'm just gonna keep my eyes
moving
yeah definitely not an anomaly there
that they're just going to be there for
six hours oh there's a lot of rooms here
how many rooms we got a lot we do have a
lot okay that was all of them okay I
really got a scan and look carefully
I was stunned I was honestly stunned
that I don't like you I was stunned that
I actually managed to do it
last time
hey guys hi good to see you is that a
coffin probably
oh
oh where am I hallway that was obvious
okay thank you
I'm sure that no one lives here and
that's actually a horrifying anomaly
I can't normally fixed just keep
scanning no matter what jumps out of me
no matter what looks strange
keep scanning God I know this from the
last time that when I was looking before
like the strangest things jump out to my
attention and then there are other
things that just like I will never have
seen ever
I'm trying to like hone in on certain
objects in each one and like say them in
my head so that at least I have some
kind of building memory to all of this
trying to notice a new detail every
single time because that could be the
detail that I missed like I didn't even
know this cork board was here
oh
thanks this or this order of things is
probably very important there is a shoe
back here uh trash bag that is weird
block wine bottle weird painting that
was their teeth face choo choo train
there's a cup there the Fan's on toilet
paper that's fine nothing's different
one shampoo bottle one towel TV papers
on the ground Rubble caution out of
order this weirdo uh that shoe five four
papers one book The Fragile brick wall
uh there's not a whole lot here unless
I'm missing something two lights two
windows a gas can these dudes
not an anomaly for some reason that's
definitely not an anomaly weird thing
crawling out of the painting one shoot
all the good there this year I thought I
saw something in the window there
wait was that fridge always like that
oh no I have no idea
now I might have missed something here
no I don't have any idea
oh boy
oh that can't be right
that that
our audio anomalies a part of this
[Music]
why would you do that oh no I guess
noises can happen every any anywhere and
it's not really a big deal if they do
part of life that is
there something on my monitor or is
there something in the window over there
I don't know I don't know
oh boy
oh no
I feel like I'm missing something
that tickling in the back of my mind
there was a box on the boxes whoa wait a
minute the trash bags are different
there was one trash bag in the alley I
like two
I'm almost positive there was one trash
bag not four
oh man
the shoes moved the hallway got longer
never mind
shoes didn't move the hallway got longer
yeah that ain't right okay
all right good good
one trash bag there was that always
there probably I'm gonna assume yes God
this is gonna suck I've already burned
up two of my chances
[Music]
oh okay this is all defined in that same
order
this is fine nothing in the windows
looks like something's in the windows
but nothing's in the windows lights on
yeah these dudes are these the same
dudes
they look like the guy who does the food
reviews in the suit
which is a compliment
of course
I have not seen this man I don't want to
see that man
is that the same if that's the same guy
from the supermarket I I really really
don't want to see him I'm so missing
something
no I knew it I'm missing something I
don't know what I'm missing though this
is an emergency multiple yeah uh-huh
yeah uh-huh
uh-huh I don't know a multiple active
anomalies
oh my god well I might as well pick one
and I I feel like it's in here the
kitchen
oh what changed
I don't know
wait was it was it like that was off
wait a minute
is that how minute the details are going
to be because I don't remember even
seeing that in the first place oh man
oh man
oh is that always like build it over
like that
was there always some I would I would I
would have I would I would have I would
have I would have I should have I would
have remembered if that was there
wouldn't I have wouldn't I have
oh
it's over God damn it
I fixed three anomalies okay that's
abysmal that's terrible but I wasn't
familiar enough I'm gonna go back the
apartment because I like this where I
don't have to report what type I just
have to remember what it is okay I'm
looking at this that's the same is it
giving me the same base startup because
that's awfully convenient that is very
helpful because if it's the same base
then I can go through these and I can
see what
could possible maybe the number was
different oh do I have to remember the
number
or the cork board was the cork board not
there or something no I I said there
wasn't there was no anomaly these guys
did change they got younger that's why
they looked like the review guy they
didn't look like that before
oh man
Elise is giving me the same base because
that's that's a good sign I think it
might have been that lighter maybe the
cabinet over there
something bad carpet
teeth
Turtle it light
laundry plug radiator
it is insane how I notice a new thing
the picture is on there but there was
nothing in here there was nothing in
here that was different
there's four candles by the looks of it
that might have been something different
a gas can these guys you stay old what
else is in here I'm not even missing I'm
not even paying attention to the rest of
this lights on top briefcases in left
hand door
four bags coffin screw plier ashtray
broken TV buckets
you gotta like relax your eyes and just
let it all sink in you can't look at it
oh my God
don't are you kidding me don't do that
what is wrong with you
what around you
good God okay well that was an easy
anomaly to see okay
any more weird faces just gonna be in
laundry machines
is that going to be a thing
weird upside down train
laundry
look at the fear hiccups
I don't know why this game is like tense
it just feels tense something about it
it's just different it's not what I'm
used to there's a tiny Shadow there I
don't think that matters nothing else
here
cup it's empty trash can
weird things
uh
probably missing something there's a
book there caution out of order
I have not seen that dude
oh God I'm definitely missing something
how
still old still old good
oh okay
all right so I missed it opening but at
least that I've seen before
you thank you
okay normally fixed
light is on nothing else is on weird
faces
bathroom shampoo two things no faces
[Music]
sign on door that is illegible
fragile
I thought I heard something better not
have heard something old
oh come on subconscious please was there
always a book there there's a book there
now book there a book there
oh okay all right old
wait was that always pointing that way
my brain says that that may not have
been pointing that way
it was it was it definitely was this is
the waste
okay it's pointing into the circle
that's for sure now I know that yippee
yippee hooray and in doing that I
probably missed another anomaly oh my
god oh well God where's the entrance
huh well if they're always going to be
obvious like this and I'm not going to
have a problem here
myself more I don't think it like
this time I think it just ended my own
run voluntarily was there always a book
that it just fixed itself of course
there was it's probably a good thing
though because I'm starting to tune it
in
to the point where little details like
that are jumping
out at me
are you sure these guys aren't an
anomaly they look anomalous
very uncomfortable
are there always two shoes there must
have been though I know there was
something behind that shoe I just didn't
see what it was maybe probably not
oh
shoes are gone who took the shoes that's
probably just a thief more than an
anomaly
but anomaly it is
I'm okay with this not reporting the
exact specific type that I'm okay with
because if this can just go a bit
smoother for me
everyone's gonna be happy right guys
everyone's gonna be happy
meme was that light I feel like it
always was must have been there's no way
that it wouldn't have cast light
therefore if it was drastically
different it would be more different
than that I don't think the difference
is going to be like this trash bag moves
like two inches to the right still the
face is there still light on here
was the stove always white yes yes
I'm gonna go with yes
hey wait a minute something
did you do something different I don't
notice when my friends get haircuts so
how am I going to notice when you guys
do did you guys not feel that or
anything did you guys not notice
hey wait a minute who turned that chair
I know what's going on didn't turn the
screwdriver definitely turn the chair
okay that's easy enough I can do that I
can deal with that man I don't know why
but it did seem in in observation Duty
four it did seem a lot more daunting
with the amount of objects I think they
the developer probably reduced it down
just a little bit it's just a little
more manageable I don't even know what
that is
coffee.com no
I got too back to back I don't know if
that was just a random assortment of two
that just so happened to appear
I think that's the alert that's gonna be
like you're missing 10 different
anomalies
which I probably am
you can't go stretching on me no
elongation allowed
I'm not about that you get back in your
place door
that's right
chair there probably was always a chair
there and I just didn't notice
Maybe
was there always a chair there how could
I have not seen the chair
how is it possible that I wouldn't have
seen the chair do I gotta look at your
ties you got striped ties
there's a chair there were chairs here
of course it would be a chair it's an
office right I just didn't look at the
down
that's all it is something does feel
different but I
it's a weird wooden
curl it top so the piss can soak right
in
oh I'm missing something I am is it the
chair
to the jersey or striped ties
oh I'm missing something I know I'm I am
oh no no no no what what hey whoa hey
wait a minute you can't switchy swatchy
on me all right at least that's
something
that's good for me that's a little
something it's not a lot of something
but I don't need a lot of something I
just need to get through this goddamn
night I can miss one I think it's just
if you have multiple on there
then it gets bad if you have like three
anomalies at the same time you get
booted
satellite always on was that light
always on
oh I don't remember seeing a light there
but there's I
oh if it's that small I'm gonna be mad
if it's that small
how could I have not seen the light I
don't know
I don't know
it feels different in here
I think I think it's just a reflection I
think it's a reflection of the light at
the top that was always there it must
have always been there it must have been
it must have been these are in line
pictures
this is not different there's not much
here anyway
you're the same
what
I heard that
I don't know what I heard but I heard
something
I'm gonna get the alert that there's
multiple anomalies and then I'm gonna
look around and I'm gonna be like I
don't know what you're talking about I
don't know anything what you're talking
about everything is exactly the same as
it always has been because it is
don't do this to me
don't do this to me don't do this to me
was that some I I feel like that's not
right that's not no no no no
why would there be yes
why would there have been four switches
of course there wouldn't have been four
switches four switches ridiculous what
kind of office needs that many switches
now I gotta start looking at the the
details of the wall
of the wall dirty walls
fences brick
tile floor oh my God don't do that
you're not anomalous
you are supposed to be non-anomalous you
are not anomalous no matter how
beautiful your eyes really are you're
not anomalous
which some kind of like wallpaper painty
thing
wallpaper same wallpaper paint as the
kitchen
no I'm not looking at the red details
tile all around brick brick brick brick
a Brack
I got a report pending I got a report
pending thank you
I'm looking at the wall
hanging from the ceiling
I'm missing something what did I just
see
am I crazy
what was that
am I just seeing is this just my hair
that's it's just my hair that's like a
strands in my eye or something or I'm
crazy or I'm really seeing things
there's a door here that I didn't notice
I'm missing something
but honestly what could possibly be
missing
what was it I'm hearing noises
I'm hearing noises
and I'm seeing nothing
How can there be so much nothing
it's been too long since the last one
it's been way too long I'm in trouble
I'm in big trouble I'm in very big
trouble I'm in extremely big trouble I'm
in exceptionally huge amounts of trouble
I'm screwed I'm boned
I'm boned
box box box
box
box box box box box
box box box box box box box
okay was that like the only anomaly has
there really been nothing
oh
hearing noises God I gotta play this
with like the Toby eye tracker because
that would really go a long way
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute hold on a second there was
definitely not a second number pad
these are getting really subtle
don't like that
yeah because then you could see like how
much my eyes are just like all over the
screen just trying to grab new
information desperately trying to
commit all this stuff my memory as best
I can I feel like that rug is going to
lift up at some point
[Music]
like so you check the waveform on that
one that it was a little bump in the in
the fan noise right
yeah that's what I thought
that's what I thought
maybe there was a secret message em
added in the waveform oh come on
I don't know
just give me a break okay something new
must have just appeared
if it's going to give that warning
something must have just appeared
because now they're well hey buddy how
you doing there pal
good to see you can you go away it's out
of order by the way
okay well that at least gets me out of
the emergency but I feel like I'm just
gonna hit emergency again but I don't
see
I don't see anything different I still
hear Rubble gas can't do lights two
windows you guys I just fixed you
there's nothing there probably this is
all the same I think
this is the same but there is another
anomaly out here right now
oh frick
something's different
so something's different in alley one
it's probably not but something feels
different
why does it feel different
what was different
oh the ground was different it was
darker
ah
okay well that's good
it's good to know caught one more in
that box is not supposed to be on the
ground there that box was on the other
boxes these
foreign
okay this happened with the supermarket
as well I got the emergency warning
there but I still managed to get it all
the way through I don't know how but I
did
Hi friend sorry
I'm sorry for intruding
my apologies please be banished to the
shadow realm where you can bathe in your
own privacy
you guessed you guys decided to listen
to some music
you guys can't take the screams of the
Damned coming from outside the elevator
it's a long and boring elevator ride I
get that
um
anything to pass the time I suppose was
that box always turned that way I think
it was but um
that would be the most subtle shift that
would be extremely subtle
I don't know if like towards the end of
it it gets more subtle or less subtle
just fixed you
new here same pictures shoe pencil
same alley
same dudes
same Z's maybe don't like that
if I get kicked out for that I'm gonna
be pissed thing is if you game over it
doesn't even tell you what you game over
to
[Music]
which is extremely unhelpful
hey wait a minute
where'd the dowels go hey if those back
the guy bathing is gonna need those
probably soon
probably
all right good
oh hey it says he's back get out of here
get out of that elevator get out of
there all right one more hour and I'm
doing pretty good I'm actually doing
shockingly well and these
identifications of anomalies have kind
of like stretched the game but I might
have picked up something simultaneously
is fixing another problem
so you know I guess I should thank my
lucky stars
and I will
I will thank my lucky stars
oh
interesting okay
well that could just be normal for all I
know
probably broken TV and all that good and
the box is not rotated a different way
this is the same
this is the same is this the same yeah
it's the same yeah this is the same
and still on paintings are still the
same
this is still the same
although if I had to guess where an
anomaly was if there still is one
floating around that I haven't seen it
would probably be in that office or the
kitchen because
I have not reported either those or in
here I guess because I haven't reported
any of these in a while oh I'm missing
something I'm definitely missing
something
oh so I'm missing something
uh but what is it I'm gonna get kicked
out this oh you can't do this to me
give me an obvious one
please
oh please oh no oh no I'm doomed I'm
doomed I'm doomed I'm doomed I'm so
doomed I'm doomed I'm doomed oh I'm
doomed
come on
hey hey hey wait a minute hey wait a
minute
hey that that picture's different it's
super weird that that I know that
picture's different that is the tiniest
isotonous the details yeah but I I did
notice that one okay because I looked at
all this so you better not kick me out
of here
you better you better you better not you
better not
you better not
I got one more potential for a false
report and I need to use that probably
very intelligently
well that's strange I don't think this
one's gonna be false uh I don't know
about this Chief I don't know how about
that one that's a little bizarre
all right I think I'm gonna make it I
think with that it might get me I
thought something was weird there it
might give me Across the Threshold
because I noticed the extremely tiny
details
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you guys are the same good
stay that way
something could change here I wouldn't
be too opposed
this is the same
Z's
same Z's
same Zs
same
oh something's not right in the alley uh
I don't know if I should be in the alley
oh this don't feel too good in the alley
the alley don't feel too nice
that's remembering
observation Duty 4
I got sucked across the room right out
of my camera and I don't know how that
happens
and then I got slurped down at demons
pie hole
eight minutes left come on
please please please
give me another one come on or don't
give me any at all that would also be
really cool that would be super dope
let me survive
I don't see anything
yes yes yes click clack click clock
come on please I made it I did I did I
did I definitely did
oh
[Laughter]
yeah
that was too many anomalies what I want
to do though
I'm not going to go into another one
because I
it's too stressful
I just want to see what if there's
different rule sets to these it wasn't
it the same thing with the Metro where
it was like he just had to report
something let me just see what the house
is gonna be like so I can get it in my
head we are testing a new reporting
system
no need to report the anomaly type
anymore but too many false reports will
cause our system crash also you know
that there are no cameras outside the
house but make sure to report outside
anomalies as being outside
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you refer to what are you referring
what does bodak stand for I don't even
know
oh
lovely house is that light
that normal wow this is too much detail
I would not be able to do this
oh no it's so much detail this there's
no way
bro
bro there's no way
bro bro
it's impossible
bro bro what are you
what are you supposed to be
ah there's so many rooms
okay well this is not happening I'm I'm
out of here I just want to also see what
the next one is how about the bank the
central bank has been exposed to
anomalies we are testing a new Reporting
System no need to report the number to
tap anymore that's great
oh I had nothing else to it just Bank
wow big Bank way too big hate how big
bank is Bank big bank real big
Bank too big yeah yeah I get it an
anomalies okay I'm not doing either of
those not today but if you guys want to
see more of those let me know down in
the comments below this is a weirdly fun
game to play I probably wouldn't
dedicate more than one more video to
this but it's weirdly interesting and
I'm getting better I feel like I'm
getting smarter I feel like my brain is
expanding it's getting bigger it's
inviginating and I'm able to capture
more probably good fruit I don't know so
now I'm just gonna stand here very still
again so that you can determine if
there's any changes and just be warned
there will be
don't fail too many times or else uh
well
let's just say you're not going to get a
good night's sleep
[Music]